i'm going to give you the headline and
tell you it really shouldn't be a
headline and that's really what we're
going to be focusing in on three
republicans will be voting for joe
biden's supreme court nominee judge
katanji brown jackson wow and it has
made dozens and dozens of headlines and
yet it really shouldn't even be a
headline the reason that this is a
headline is because supreme court
confirmations have become
so
brazenly partisan
that it actually makes news when just a
few republicans are able to say wait a
second
in the senate we're supposed to
determine
is this a qualified individual to be on
the court
and if he or she is then we should vote
to confirm it seems quaint it seems
almost antiquated it seems sort of like
the uh the the way of the past because
mostly it is and we have seen hyper
partisan word salad explanations as to
why many republicans are not going to be
voting to confirm judge jackson so uh
the associated press reporting murkowski
romney back jackson all but a sure
confirmation we already know about maine
republican senator susan collins who
said she would be voting for judge
jackson's confirmation and it just makes
perfect sense the associated press
reporting republican senators lisa
murkowski and mitt romney announced they
will vote to confirm judge katanji brown
jackson
giving president joe biden's nominee a
burst of bipartisan support and all but
assuring she'll become the first black
female justice
uh republican susan collins announced
last week she would back jackson noting
her stellar qualifications
all three republicans said they did not
expect to agree with all of judge
jackson's decisions but they found her
extremely well qualified romney romney
said jackson more than meets the
standard of intelligence of excellence
and integrity murkowski said she will
bring to the supreme court a range of
experience from the courtroom that few
can match given her background in
litigation so she is going to be
confirmed and she should be confirmed
because the truth is she is arguably as
qualified as any of the nine justices
currently on the court i've referred to
this document before that was put
together which looks at the experience
and qualifications of the nine justices
currently on the court as well as as
judge jackson's and as you can see judge
jackson if you're if you're looking
judge jackson is the only the only of
the what we're talking about 10 people
the nine on the court plus her
who has this wide range of experience
um she has public high school education
which you can argue uh gives a
particular perspective that is useful
for a justice to have she has the ivy
league law school education as well
she was a supreme court clerk she is
the only of the nine plus one justices
and judge to be a public defender she is
the only other than judge sotomayor to
have been a district judge she's the
only one
other than judge breyer to have been on
a sentencing commission and of course
serving as well on uh as a judge on the
court of appeals and what's both funny
and kind of disheartening to see is that
many republicans don't even really seem
to know why they aren't voting for her
confirmation or at least they're not
willing to say it and maybe that's the
more important thing
earlier this week i played a clip for
you of republican senator roy blunt he
was asked by george stephanopoulos are
you going to support her and he said no
i'm not and when he was asked why he
went on like a 90-second word salad that
didn't make any sense something about
judicial philosophy that was completely
unintelligible
we have other examples of this here is
lindsey graham recently saying uh he is
not going to be voting to confirm judge
jackson but she's very qualified and
smart and seems to meet all the
requirements judge jackson has got a lot
to be proud of she's accomplished a lot
in her life she's a good person i'm sure
she's a great mother and
um very gifted uh
person she's
fought hard to be where she's at in life
i'll vote no i'm the first first time
i've ever voted against any supreme
court nominee here's another example of
lindsey graham as well
i find judge jackson's to be a person of
exceptionally good character
respected by our peers and someone who
has worked hard to achieve her current
position
however her record is overwhelming in
his lack of a steady judicial philosophy
and a tendency to achieve outcomes in
spite of what the law requires our
common sense would dictate
after a thorough review of judge
jackson's record and information gained
at the hearing from an evasive witness
i now know why judge jackson was the
favorite of the radical left and i will
vote no so
it's basically a meaningless statement
her judicial philosophy isn't steady in
its record now some of you have been
writing to me saying david you know why
they're not voting for her but they
can't say it they're not voting for her
because she's black
now i don't have evidence that that's
the case
what it does seem to me
is that her identity meaning
a black woman
nominated by a democrat
named kitanji
those characteristics
are making republicans
look at her record
in a different way than they would
if this was someone nominated by donald
trump with a different identity and you
don't have to look much further than for
example lindsay lindsey graham's vote
in favor of her being appointed to the
court of appeals where she currently
sits
lindsey graham is not the only
republican who has said many times well
we
she's very qualified
for other positions and when they're
asked about this what you'll often hear
from them is they'll say well
it's a different standard now because
this is the highest court of the land
someone that would be qualified for a
lower court wouldn't necessarily be
qualified for the highest court in the
land that's totally plausible it's at
least theoretically an acceptable
differentiation
they just aren't able to articulate
exactly what they mean and it's very
transparently pathetic now one other
note on mitt romney supporting her
mitt romney is a less crazy republican
there's no doubt of that not saying i
love romney not saying i want romney to
be the president of the united states
but mitt romney is a far less crazy
republican than many of these other
people at the same time we shouldn't
ignore the idea
that maybe romney is trying to just kind
of revive
the may the possibility that he could
run for president in the future although
i still don't think that he has plans to
do that he said before it's not
something he intends to get back in but
maybe mitt romney for that or other
reasons wants to kind of rehabilitate
his reputation i don't know now in the
meantime the cuckoo for coco puffs or
the um
what would we call
anyway the wacky wing of the the trump
wing of the republican party
they are coming up with wild attacks on
the three republicans that will be
supporting judge jackson including
marjorie taylor greene tweeting
murkowski collins and romney are
pro-pedophile because they plan to
support judge katanji brown jackson
that's obviously
an absurd interpretation
the question is is she qualified
the answer is yes she is
the outcome if you put these inputs into
a computer and you calculate the outcome
should be
we're going gonna vote to confirm her
and so far we know about three
republicans that will
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman